ausgelassene Partys wie hier auf dem
Christopher Street Day in Berlin hIV ist
bei vielen schwulen Männern eigentlich
kein großes Thema mehr doch im Moment
kommt in die Community plötzlich wieder
die Angst zurück vor einer HIV Infektion
Grund dafür dieses HIV Medikament fehlt
in Deutschland die prep für Jörn
falldorf ist das ein Problem er ist
einer von 40.000 prepusern und nimmt die
Tabletten um sich vor einer Ansteckung
zu schützen doch das mit Medikament ist
in Deutschland seit Wochen knapp ist
durchaus möglich dass vielleicht ich bin
in der Generation groß geworden wo eine
HIV Infektion wirklich ganz
dramatische Folgen hatte und die alte
Angst vor HIV kommt kommt wieder vor
Ansteckung und das ist ein ziemlich
beschissenes Gefühl um das mal sehr
deutlich zu sagen seine Apotheke in
Berlin Schöneberg hat sich auf HIV
Medikamente spezialisiert wie stehen
hier die Chancen noch die prep zu
bekommen
gelesen schlecht ganz ganz schlecht
momentan ist leider der Markt leer
gefegt es sind wirklich auch als wir
noch Ware hatten als na ja ich sag mal
eine der wenigen Apotheken in der
Republik das wirklich Anfragen
waren auch von weiter weg die Leute
setzen sich dafür in den Zug würden
vorbeikommen die bekannteste Safer Sex
Methode ist nach wie vor das Kondom
außerdem schützt eine Therapie HIV
Menschen nehmen dabei Medikamente die
das Virus zurückdrängen es ist bei ihnen
nicht mehr nachweisbar und Sie können
auch niemanden mehr anstecken die prep
ist die dritte Safer Sex Methode sie
wird seit 2019 von den Krankenkassen
bezahlt die prep ist eine Methode um
sich vor HIV zu schützen für Menschen
für die der durchgängige Kondomgebrauch
aus verschiedensten Gründen nicht in
Frage kommt oder nicht gut praktikabel
ist und wir sind immer noch dabei den
Menschen zu sagen hey es gibt hier eine
neue Möglichkeit wenn du ein hohes
Risiko hast dann könnte das auch etwas
für Dich sein und jetzt wird das
Vertrauen in diese gerade gewonnene neue
Methode erschüttert weil man plötzlich
das Medikament nicht mehr erhält das ist
fatal für die einzelnen Menschen aber
auch für die HIV Prävention insgesamt
Grund für den Mangel zwei Hersteller
haben die Produktion eingestellt um das
zu kompensieren hat Gesundheitsminister
Lauterbach offiziell einen
Versorgungsengpass für die prep
ausgerufen die ampelregierung erlaubt
also dass das Medikament leichter aus
dem Ausland importiert werden kann
wir gehen davon aus dass es ein
vorübergehender Mangel ist im Moment ist
davon auszugehen dass ab Ende Februar
wieder genügend Medikamente geliefert
werden können auch weil die Hersteller
zugesagt haben früher als geplant
ihre Produktionskapazitäten hochzufahren
wir rechnen damit dass für diesen
vorübergehenden Zeitraum durch den
verstärkten Import einer größeren Anzahl
an Medikamenten aus dem Ausland nach
Deutschland der Bedarf gedeckt werden
kann das Beispiel prep steht für ein
generelles Problem in Deutschland
aktuell sind fast 500 Arzneimittel knapp
Antibiotika Krebsmedikamente
antidepressiver die Produktion lohnt
sich oft nicht kritisiert die Opposition
im Grunde haben wir das Problem dass wir
sehr fragile Lieferketten haben das ist
auch eine Problematik der Globalisierung
aufgrund des Kostendrucks in den letzten
Jahren haben viele Kassen Rabattverträge
geschlossen da ist dann immer der
billigste zum Zug gekommen und das hat
zur Folge gehabt dass andere Anbieter im
Markt ihre Produkte überhaupt nicht
anbieten konnten und das führt dann dazu
dass es medikamentenengpäse gibt bereits
im vergangenen Jahr hatte
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach Besserung
versprochen Medikamente wollte er
vermehrt in Europa herstellen lassen und
fiebersäfte für Kinder wurden für die
Hersteller profitabler sie konnten 50%
mehr dafür bekommen doch das reicht
nicht sagen
Hersteller man hat immer dann wenn ein
Engpass da war eine neue Gesetzgebung
versucht zu initiieren das ist keine
Strategie ja die Patienten in
Deutschland erwarten eine sichere
Versorgung sie Zahl alle viel Geld für
die Krankenkassen für die Beiträge und
das kriegen wir nur hin wenn wir eine
Strategie haben eine
versorgungsstrategie und wegkommen von
dieser symptomenbasierten Lösung wo ich
für jedes Problem ein neues Pflaster
sozusagen üers Problem klebe kritik gibt
es auch an Lauterbachs Kommunikation in
Sachen prep Ende Januar musste er
eingestehen dass das Medikament noch
wochenlang knapp sein wird verbunden mit
dem Rad bis dahin bitte vorsichtig
sein das der Aufruf da jetzt einfach des
Ministers Kondome zu benutzen solangee
ich bitte um Verständnis dass ich jetzt
Äußerungen des Ministers nicht weiter
kommentieren kann ja vorsichtig sein wir
reden über Sex wir reden nicht über
Mathematik wir reden nicht über
binomische Formeln Sex passiert im affek
da ist Gefühl dabei da ist Ektase dabei
und da ist der Verstand nicht das
Regulativ und dann vorsichtig zu sein
ist ist verdammt schwierig ich hätte so
ein Satz vielleicht anders v formuliert
und vielleicht auch einfach mal geschaut
dass sich die Versorgungslage ändert das
ist jetzt das was wir brauchen
inzwischen haben Hersteller zusätzliche
Lieferungen angekündigt experten rechnen
aber damit dass die prep noch bis Mitte
März knapp bleiben wird das Problem
bleibt der Community erst einmal
erhalten